consider the density curve below and so
we have a density curve that describes
the probability distribution for a
continuous random variable this random
variable can take on values from 1 to 5
and has an equal probability of taking
on any of these values from 1 to 5 find
the probability that X is less than 4 so
X can go from 1 to 4 there's no
probability that will be less than 1 so
we know the entire area under the
density curve is going to be 1 so if we
can find a fraction of the area that
meets our criteria then we know the
answer to the question so what we're
going to look at is we want to go from 1
to 4 the reason why I know we can start
at 1 is there's no probability there's
zero chances that I'll get a value less
than 1 we see that from the density
curve and so we just need to think about
what is the area here what is this area
right over here well this is just a
rectangle where the height is 0.25 and
the width is 1 2 3 so our area is going
to be 0.25 times 3 which is equal to
0.75 so the probability that X is less
than 4 is 0.75 or you could say it's a
75% probability let's do another one of
these are slightly more involved in a
density curve a set of middle school
students Heights are normally
distributed with the mean of 150
centimeters and a standard deviation of
20 centimeters let H be the height of a
randomly selected student from this set
find and interpret the probability that
H that the height of a randomly selected
student from the set is greater than 170
centimeters so let's first visualize the
density curve it is a normal
distribution they tell us that the mean
is 150 centimeters so let me draw that
so the mean that is 150
and they also say that we have a
standard deviation of 20 centimeters so
20 centimeters above the mean one
standard deviation above the mean is 170
one standard deviation below the mean is
130 and we want the probability of if we
randomly select from these middle school
students what's the probability that the
height is greater than 170 so that's
going to be this area under this normal
distribution curve it's going to beat
that area so how can we figure that out
well there's several ways to do it we
know that this is the area above one
standard deviation above the mean you
could use a Z table or you could use
some generally useful knowledge about
normal distributions and that's that the
area between one standard deviation
below the mean and one standard
deviation above the mean this area right
over here is roughly 68% it's closer to
68.2%
for our purposes 68 will work fine and
so if we're looking at just from the
mean to one standard deviation above the
mean it would be half of that so this is
going to be approximately 34% now we
also know that for a normal distribution
the area below the mean is going to be
50% so we know all of that is 50% and so
the combined area below 170 below one
standard deviation above the mean is
going to be 84 percent or approximately
84 percent and so that helps us figure
out what is the area above one standard
deviation above the mean which will
answer our question the entire area
under this density curve under any
density curve is going to be equal to
one and so the entire area is one this
green area is 84 percent or 0.8 for well
then we just subtract that from 1 to get
this blue area so this is going to be 1
minus 0.8 4 I'll say approximately and
so that's going to be approximately 0.16
if you want a slightly more precise
value
you could use a Z table the area below
one standard deviation above the mean
will be closer to about eighty four
point one percent in which case this
would be about fifteen point nine
percent or 0.15 nine but you can see
that we got pretty close by knowing the
general rule that it's roughly 68%
between one standard deviation below the
mean and one standard deviation above
the mean for a normal distribution